if we take something like any fiction
and any holy book in any other figure
and destroyed it okay in a thousand
years time that wouldn't come back just
as it was whether we took every science
book yes right and every fact and
destroyed them all in a thousand years
they'd all be back because all the same
tests would be the same result
that was our friend ricky gervais he
made a very bold statement
you see if you took every holy book as
we holy book has ever been every
religious book every bitter spirituality
and hid them or destroyed them okaying
that went away and never right then you
took every science book and destroyed
that in a thousand years time those
science books will be back exactly the
same
because the text would always turn out
the same right those religious book with
other never exist or they'd be totally
different because there's no there's no
time now for someone who doesn't know it
makes sense if you took like he said all
of the religious holy texts to all the
Bible's the versions of the Bible's all
the other holy texts take the Koran
throw it away get rid of it
drown it burn it lock it up he said that
it'll never come back as it was now that
is true there's there's there's actually
actually there's fact but there's some
fiction in there you want to share this
with Ricky who's a very well-known
famous TV personality comedian and
hopefully he can listen to this because
we're all prone to error when we don't
know when the facts haven't come to us
when the information there's so much
information and this is this is the this
is why it's so important for us to get
out there and share Islam because this
is one of the miracles that proved that
Islam is indeed from the Creator this
fact that the Quran is the only book all
the other ones would perish would
disappear you wouldn't be able to bring
them back but that is why Islam is
unique because we have a book that if
you did burn all the crimes if you got
them you drown them you you lock them up
this book would be the only book that
you could actually bring back and it has
stood the test of time if you look this
is a factual statement kids at a young
age young age of five six seven have
memorized the entire book like no other
book in the world
I love the crime when I was seven years
old I memorized the Quran when I was ten
and it took me one year and a half we
started the flight literally was three
years old no matter where you go in the
world whether it be in China whether it
be in Africa whether it be in Asia or in
the Middle East
no matter where you go in the world
because one foot on this is one of the
toughest and the students in Australia
who memorize the Quran it is then
continuing on with this great rich and
deep tradition of the moment our friend
Ricky look into it and anyone else who's
a fan of Ricky's who's watching this
video this is pro/5 you didn't know now
you know this is what differentiates
Islam from the other religions which we
say our man-made religions but Islam if
you look at look into it look into the
Quran you guys ever watch Magnum wha-hey
Oh Wally when a clunky Harvard mr. he
was before
wonderful he's um I don't
[Music]
and you'll be amazed there's no other
book like the book it is impossible for
an illiterate man who lived 14 centuries
ago to know and mention all of these
things and the Quran can only be the
book of the being that created the
universe for the Quran miraculously
mentions everything that the book of the
universe includes and all of its news
turns out to be true of the Quran
compiled over 23 years so many
scientific fact signs in there that
prove that it couldn't have been written
by a man or a group of man nations
coming together to produce a book like
this it's impossible attention has been
drawn to this information miraculously
in the verses of the Quran just like
many other scientific facts it is a
proof that the Quran is the word of
Allah since there is so much detailed
and true information within the Quran
sent down at a time when humanity did
not have any detailed information on the
subject it is not possible for any sane
person to accept the second alternative
therefore the Quran is the pre-eternal
word of Allah as the miraculous verses
that astonish man but that's the point I
just wanted to focus on was the fiction
that he had stated just not knowing we
all make mistakes hopefully he can
listen to this and this and get to him
and our friend Ricky can be amazed like
so many other people who have accepted
Islam because when they've looked into
the Quran they've seen like wow there's
nothing like it there's nothing like
this book and yeah where I'm not going
to get in and I might we probably do a
show on this in the future about the
scientific test because you might know
how some functions but that doesn't
eliminate the existence of a creator
because that's the other point he had
talked about was that the scientific
test would be come back they wouldn't
come back the same what day the text
that they've written that something off
for debate
and even if they did come back the test
that doesn't because we know something
how many calories how many nutrients how
the clouds worked I've reduced the rain
and cetera et cetera that doesn't
eliminate the one who created the clouds
in the whole universe and everything and
it doesn't mr. Ricky so look into this
point and hopefully we can maybe get you
on the Dean show we can go ahead you had
a nice little talk about this with
Cobert maybe you can come and talk to us
meet some muslims and look into this
qur'an like no other book and yes it
would be the only book that you could
actually bring back because it's the
only book that has stood the test of
time in academics non-muslim academics
have verified that this Quran is the
same as it was revealed and we have over
10 million if I'm not mistaken people
who have today memorize the entire book
that is mind-blowing this entire book
try memorizing a book of 10 20 pages let
alone 6236 ayahs verses memorized like I
said by kids and adults and it's
preserved we have it today it's a living
miracle talks about the purpose of life
why we're here where we're going were
when we die beautiful teachings it's in
this book and it's the verbatim Word of
God like no other book identifying that
it's from the Creator too much to talk
about this is just a short response to
our friend Ricky who made this claim I
just wanted to politely address it and
hopefully this can get to him and he can
get this and investigate it look into it
it's amazing thank you very much
comment below if you want to see us
cover a full episode on this we can
really go ahead and dwell into this
topic it's very deep subscribe right now
if you haven't liked this video share
this video so God willing you can get to
our friend Ricky we'll see you next time
here on the D show every Friday new show
please be with you Saamy
right
[Applause]